wo ist ein
[Musik]
aber ich habe mein terminplan verlegte
screen gesehen
egal ich bin weiter suchen nicht ich
telefoniere
achtung frisch gewischt
was macht lisa tja die macht wieder
alles gleichzeitig die telefoniert
während sie die sachen zusammenpackt und
es stört mich auch überhaupt nicht dass
sie hier ständig durch das früheste
wohnzimmer rennt während sie telefoniert
kann schauen
du siehst doch ist dieser stress hat du
bist jetzt wieder auf ihrer seite
wenn man sie noch vertragen ja außerdem
ist streit auch ein stressfaktor und ich
muss mich warum musst du dich entspannen
darum heißt es du behältst das baby nina
termin beim frauenarzt der ist doch um
halb vier oder ja aber ich kann auch
alleine gehen
es kommt gar nicht infrage ich hab sie
doch versprochen während wir beim arzt
sind kann ich auch noch ein bisschen auf
meinem laptop arbeiten wir sind unserer
praxis ja okay okay dann hast du
toilettenpapier gekauft
stressfaktoren über ein stressfaktoren